قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ما
راي زخارفا ان تزويد كيف بمنظومات باتريوت
يزيد من خطر المشاركه المباشره للجيش
الامريكي في الصراع الاوكراني
من الغرب ستكون اهداف مشروعه بالنسبه
لروسيا سيجري تدميرها او الاستيلاء عليها
وتبعتنا واشنطن لن تكون قادره على التهرب
من مسؤوليه ما وصفته بالارهاب ضد الشعب
اذا كما ذكرت الخروف الخارجيه الروسيه
قالت ان جميع الاسلحه المرسله لاوكرانيا
من الغرب اهداف مشروعه لروسيا وسوف يتم
تدميرها او الاستيلاء عليها كما حذرت من
امكانيه تزويد الولايات المتحده كيف
بانظمه باتريوت الصاروخيه للدفاع الجوي
وقالت زخرفه من شان هذه الخطوه ان تؤدي
الى تصعيد الصراع وتزيد من تورط الجيش
الامريكيه المباشر في الاعمال القتاليه في
اوكرانيا
الاميره
صاروخيه للدفاع الجويديه وفي هذا السياق
شكك العديد من الخبراء بما في ذلك من حلف
الاطلسي في حكمه مثل هذه الخطوه التي تؤدي
الى تصيد الصراع وتزيد من خطر التورط
المباشر للجيش الامريكي في العمل القتاليه
والسياسيه الذي تقدمه الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا
الشنطه الثالثه عشر من ديسمبر
صاروخيا على مدينه
تاتي بمباركه من الولايات المتحده التي
تشارك في تصوير الضربات الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه وتمد النظام الاوكراني بمعلومات
استقباريه
اصبحت عمليا
من تورطها في الارهاب الذي يخترفه نظام
قياس ضد المدنيين الروس